if the NBA brought back Christmas
Jerseys it'll be the best holiday gift
for everyone it all started in 2012 when
Adidas designed a simplistic unicolor
themed uniform and introduced us to the
first ever Christmas Day jerseys for all
10 teams on the hardwood that day The
Following Season we were all introduced
to short sleeve jerseys and the
resounding response was discussed the
jerseys weren't a hit but the Jingle
Bells commercial ad gave us one of the
best basketball commercials we've ever
seen Adidas cut the sleeves the
following year placed the team logo on
the front of the jerseys put a name
plate on the back and did away with last
names in 2015 we got a more festive font
style throughout the jersey that felt
like Santa's elves designed them by hand
and in 2016 the league perfected the
festive font for one of the best jerseys
we've ever seen which Christmas jersey
was your favorite and would you like to
see them make a comeback